willkommen zum blog mail ist tag nummer
acht
heute bin ich immer noch in köln
gestern waren wir bei moos und re wies
geburtstag und ich bin dann erst am 10
aufgestanden und hab dann so um elf
anfangen wieder zu schneiden es ist
jetzt halb vier und das video liegt
gerade hoch ich bin froh dass es
geschafft hat obwohl wir gestern feiern
waren
ich freue mich auf jeden fall auf die
tage die hier noch in köln so kommen
werden
und heute geht es aber mit dem feiern
gleich weiter und kelly ist jetzt eben
noch mal kurz weg dann muss ich auch
gleich schon los weil ich muss ein
outfit kaufen denn diese party hat ein
motto ein hauch von weiss ich weiß nicht
genau was das bedeutet ich bin schlecht
bei sowas also ich liebe aufgaben und so
kleine challenges aber bei outfits ich
habe einfach kein gefühl ich glaube ich
bin einfach nicht jemand der sich gut
anziehen kann weswegen ich habe köln hat
gute leben dann müssen wir erstmal in
die innenstadt dafür
und dann müssen wir mal schauen ich
würde die kamera auch mit zum event
nehmen ich weiß nicht ob mainz darf ob
das gewollt ist oder nicht
ich bin nicht so oft auf social media
events ich bin da ehrlich mit euch
eigentlich sollten caddy und ich heute
noch plätzchen backen und uns filmen wie
wir uns schminken
ich kann mir vorstellen dass nicht eine
von den beiden sachen passieren wird das
kann ich euch noch zu der party von
gestern hatten die party war ganz cool
ich habe allerdings nicht viel trinken
wollen weil glock muss ich bin mir da
nicht mit dem kater tag eigentlich das
so reinhauen und dann na ja einfach
nicht schneiden können jetzt noch video
hochladen und dann geht der spaß los und
ich bin so traurig
dass ich einfach die nächsten tage keine
kalender
ich bin echt schön traurig ich spiele
das gerade aber ich bin wirklich extrem
traurig dass ich meine balance kalender
ich bin einfach ich bin christmas typ so
ich liebte es und wenn ich mein
adventskalender nicht habe dann wisst
ihr katee sackhoff frische umgezogen die
wohnung ist hier nicht dekoriert mir
fehlt einfach dieses weihnachten in
deine fresse haue ich habe dass ich
jetzt sehe ich das mit wie 16
oh mein gott mein ich bier kabel werden
nach haben ausweis gefragt und leute
denkt daran wasser zu bringen so ich bin
jetzt red i mein' videos oben kellys
immer noch unterwegs und deswegen muss
ich jetzt einkaufen gehen und ich war
noch nie alleine unterwegs in köln
ich glaube ich war immer nur mit
erlebter wegs und ich fühle mich jetzt
so richtig als ob meine mama mir so
zeigen möchte dass ich als auch alleine
schaffen muss ich muss in die innenstadt
das wird ist nicht so schwer kommt mein
pony will ich mittlerweile einfach nur
noch abgeben keine ahnung dass das noch
es hier ja ich bin ganz cool sicherung
bei bipa carsten dann wird da schon drin
ist und ja ich muss was weiß es finden
keine ahnung
lustigerweise habe ich die ganze ich
habe auch winzer haben wir gerne sagt
can you feel the love tonight gesungen
und dann dachte ich so oft kommt für den
block versuche ich es auch nochmal aber
dann ist mir eingefallen das duell
angesagt hat das weil sie immer gesungen
haben in den autos oder in den blogs
dass die videos dem monaten die idee
monetarisiert wurden und dann frage ich
mich wenn ich jetzt singen würde
kenny wird
[Musik]
ob das im monat ihre dem monitor wird
ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal drin
mal gucken vielleicht dann weiß für die
zukunft so ich muss jetzt in jeder stadt
begleitet mich wir haben halt überhaupt
nicht mehr viel zeit und ich stehe hier
und rede mit euch bedeutet mir aber auch
soviel meine jacke hat so ein filz stoff
und ich kann absolut kein rucksack oder
so damit tragen aber selbst auch an den
armen
diese aneinander reiben kaputt das macht
sie dann so dass ihr das so krause licht
[Musik]
abschluss gefunden und sie die alleine
andere kunden im laden
oh mein gott das süße haben sind
noch schöner wäre wenn ihre menge
bekannten auch ja ja ich glaube einfach
für die stimme und habe mich nimm dir
mal hier die typen hassen und dann hat
sie gesagt liebe ringe
normal wie bei rewe da haben die
laktosefrei yoga trinkt ja der wird erst
mal ausprobiert
[Musik]
das erinnert sich dass heidelberg zu
diesem großen jagd so dass auch nicht
zwei orangen dann kannst du den ich an
die verschimmeln bei mir weil ich keine
orangen als ist den orangen wenn du dich
ist dann beschwert doch die es sich zu
meiner zeit essen
diese ecke aus deutschland eine avocado
hätte ich gerne ja was man jetzt welche
die könnten
ich weiß nicht wann diese narben hat
deutet
nimm die doch einfach jetzt geschneit
und so
und dass sie auf jeden fall gebrauchen
immer natürlich krank werden und ja ich
beleuchte champagner trinken müssen
champagner kaufen hatten chemischen zwei
millionen nicht einfließen
wir könnten uns theoretisch auch so
einholen
zwei flaschen von das aber das ist ja
dann megatonnen wir probieren jetzt
bubble tea aus neuen babbel klar ja
kelly freust du dich auf diesem neuen
damit wir wirklich frische paprika
schmecken
aber ich hier zumindest
[Musik]
freund von deutschland sein
da halte ich es vergessen haben wir zeit
für die sehen wir noch mal zu gucken mit
sich nicht so dass wir zuerst machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
den schuldenberg von der sonne aus prey
was für erwartungen habt ihr den
heutigen abend also heute erwarte ich
viel weihnachtliche stimmung viel
flüssiges glück fiel so bisschen schnell
alle ich erwarte und felix sehen ich
erwarte folgendes diese party wird gut
aber ich vermute dies auch
[Musik]